bonjour académicienne bonjour
académicien
elle révise avant de venir à Marie
carrière c'est pas possible
j'y brillante aussi
excusez-moi c'est à toi Maurice Marion
oui un pêcheur de vesing au Tyrol a été
condamné à une grosse amende pour avoir
péché par colère et par esprit plutôt
mordant à quoi a-t-il donc été accusé
par un homme qui le regardait péché
faites-vous aider par votre voisin il a
été pêchez vous entendez pêcher péché ou
pêcher le péché mortel
[Applaudissements]
alors attendez qu'est-ce qui peut mettre
un pêcheur en colère c'est que poisson
un monsieur qui se croit très malin et
qui lui dit sans arrêt sa mort sa mort
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ah c'est ça
exaspéré par ces questions maintenant
vous saurez que ça mord monsieur ah
d'accord
ouvrez l'enveloppe Marion ouvrez donc
l'enveloppe qui est devant vous et vous
allez voir que c'est un métier que vous
allez mimer disons écoutez parce que
c'est un métier qui a un rapport un
petit peu avec j'ai besoin d'accessoires
là notre profession allez-y un métier
qui a un rapport avec notre professeur
mais est-ce que vous avez
alors c'est un mime un métier qui est un
rap un rapport avec nos professions
ainsi
un discours de marché
réponse de du métier du mime de
marie-angamme
expliquez-nous un petit peu ce que vous
faisiez tout à l'heure si j'étais devant
j'étais devant un micro j'ai regardé des
filets une bande magnétique sur laquelle
il y avait un texte écrit et puis après
je l'ai doublé c'est à dire qu'il y
avait deux trois personnages d'un dessin
animé il y avait trois personnages
différents qu'il fallait doubler
sous l'image pour doubler un film on
voit le texte
et on le et on le dit ça s'appelle du
doublage
il faut être synchrone avec les paroles
et l'image d'accord voilà alors bon
nombre d'entre vous faites ce genre
d'exercice André n'a pas trouvé en
vaincre en revanche René Jean a noté
double de film ce que ça hein
vous trouverez
le titre d'un film non certainement pas
drôle vous connaissez depuis de longues
années ça n'a pas changé alors le titre
du film ah d'accord ah oui non mais
alors le problème c'est que je peux pas
le faire toute seule parce que c'est un
genre de truc qu'on fait à deux ça au
moins et bien choisi un partenaire
je peux vous choisir si vous voulez mais
qu'est-ce que vous aimez faire à deux je
ne sais pas il y a des heures où non non
c'est bon c'est des massages ça c'est
des massages
[Rires]
on dirait sa matière
un film
c'est pas ça alors c'est un film
c'est pas la femme la femme résultat du
tableau des 9 Marion alors le film en
question il s'agissait de une
marionnette le film il s'agit il
s'agissait du jouet
[Musique]
réponse de Maurice l'automate ça n'est
pas ça réponse de Marie-Laure Orange
Mécanique alors là
Marion je vais mourir mais non
Isabelle mire Perrine pélenne Fabienne
serra qui est l'intrus
la première parce qu'elle doit pas
monter sur des skis mais sur des patins
à roulettes
bonne réponse Jean Marais
Jean et oui vous avez bien fait de venir
Carmen Faust Guillaume Tell Lakmé
qui est l'intrus Carmen Faust Guillaume
Tell Lakmé
Guillaume tel qui est le Rossini bonne
réponse et non d'un auteur français
Marion
deux gars coraux Pissarro Sisley oui
Sisley parce qu'il est anglais parce que
ce n'est pas un impressionniste merci le
dernier des 9 c'est Jean Marais qui je
pourrais tienne le tableau des neufs
avec Marion Game qui devra mimer cette
semaine encore un proverbe Alain vous
décachetez l'enveloppe qui se trouve
devant vous je croyais
déjà de l'argent pas du tout c'est un
bon Fabien et ben ça fait rien je
reviendrai quand même qu'est-ce qu'il y
a marqué
alors 30 secondes Marion pour mimer ce
proverbe dès maintenant s'il vous plaît
il faut que je laisse mon micro
peut-être là
ah oui le lièvre et la tortue
puisqu'on a encore quelques secondes
vous nous mimez peut-être une deuxième
fois le merveilleux mime de tout à
l'heure alors faites des commentaires
maintenant académicienne académicien
c'est un proverbe à votre avis
Maggie a bien noté t'en va à la cruche à
l'eau
qu'à la fin elle se casse tout le monde
double des gains
alors Marion ou quand quoi comment
pourquoi
les nouveautés quand maintenant plus
jamais et puis qu'est-ce qu'elle était
quoi
on arrête pas de rire
c'est vraiment acharné pour qu'on rit et
on rit beaucoup beaucoup
merveilleux et je suis mariage
Jean-Jacques et puis nous avons aussi
Angelo Bardi et puis peur d'être
souplesse qui est Patrice non plus et
puis plein de jeunes il y a quatre je
suis dans les vieilles maintenant soyons
même mis du côté des Viennes
mais non je suis je suis une maman
maintenant je suis une maman ça fait un
moment je
merveilleux
rapidement les enfants il y a un petit
garçon qui est formidable qui est là
d'ailleurs bonjour Stéphane hier qui est
un tout petit garçon et puis deux filles
il y a Alexandra Joffo et Lydie Rigaud
il y a aussi deux jeunes gens qui sont
merveilleux qui sont
Christian Laurent et Jean-Georges tarot
je crois que j'ai cité tout le monde et
puis Jean-Jacques bien sûr tout le monde
est merveilleux merci beaucoup
20h30
lequel des trois le fusil à deux coups
c'est aussi un jeu de cartes
très sérieusement je crois qu'il
faudrait quand elle a gentillesse de me
laisser poser des questions pour que ça
s'adresse j'aimerais quand même
comprendre la question oui le fusil à
deux coups c'est aussi un jeu de cartes
une pompe à eau ou un roulement de
tambour à votre avis jouez pour vous
jouer dans l'intérêt des candidats qui
ont besoin vendredi de beaucoup de sous
pour partir avec des cadeaux oh là là
c'est
récupérer la pompe vous dites la pompe
qu'en pensez-vous et non hélas c'est un
jeu de cartes
[Musique]